next an orchestra of students
from one of the world's great science
and engineering universities
comes together for the world premiere of
a new piece of music
a tribute to the events of the arab
spring
meet the composer it feels like actually
the tempo of it slides
yes the conductor if you end a phrase
with a quarter note
hold it full note value and the student
performers i thought it was really
phenomenal the way he uses different
colors and
the way they kind of play off each other
i really really enjoyed it
the massachusetts institute of
technology wind ensemble presents
awakening
activists in cairo today pressed their
demands that egypt's military ruler
stepped down
immediately i can remember driving to
mit on my commute
and listening to the radio demonstrators
say they'll intensify pressure
for an end to army and hearing the
passion
in the voices of the people who were
participating in the arab spring
if i could somehow get someone to write
a piece of music
that would have our students have to
think about the arab spring movement
what it means
and get some historical context as it's
happening
right now that was my goal we are
extremely honored to have an mit alum
back on campus jamsheed sharifi
hey everyone jamshid sharifi is a new
york-based composer and producer
he's an artist that is equally
comfortable in the fields of world music
in pop music in composing original music
in writing music for film
i'm i'm digging it it sounds really good
in here too he graduated from mit
in the mid 1980s and he directed for a
number of years the
mit festival jazz ensemble so here is
someone
who really knows what it's like to make
music at mit
how it feels
we think of mit as one of the world's
great institutions for engineering and
science
but in fact the arts and humanities have
been thriving here for decades
and i think it's something that's been a
part of the fabric of mit for many many
years but it's not as well known
awakening is a piece for wind ensemble
that i've written on the theme of the
arab spring
one thing that i tried to avoid is
thinking that i was going to make any
sort of definitive statement about the
arab spring
close to two years after things have
happened it's still a
feeling of guarded optimism
it's not a piece of traditional arabic
music my records
neither are traditional persian music or
middle eastern music
they're a mix of a lot of different
elements a lot of things that i've heard
and studied i mean i
have an education in jazz i spent a lot
of time playing classical music i've
played in pop bands
i mean i'm a hybridized person right i'm
a half persian and half american so i'm
pretty comfortable
mixing those influences
i've had a fantasy for quite some time
to have him write for the mit wind
ensemble he's never composed
for the idiom of a wind ensemble a
company of woodwind brass and percussion
players and he's someone who has
a kind of artistic restraint in his
temperament
that colors in a very beautiful way
everything he does in music
when you're dealing with a new piece in
front of an ensemble
the first thing you do is play it
through and let them make their
statement
before you have anything to say
we reworked the ending a little bit we
got to hear specifically jamshed talking
to fred
and to kind of see those two come
together was a lot of fun i think i
maybe went too far
the other way so i kind of have to bring
it back but it's better than the ink
that's all i can say
middle eastern music has a lot of
quarter tones but when you're writing
for
a college win ensemble you can't expect
them to learn how to play quarter tones
you know in one concert cycle
he said for him it was interesting to
have to figure out how to get that
element in the music in it
the baritone sound is just amazing to me
the trumpet solos the
woodwind features they just all come
together really well
i've never really seen the
quote unquote division between the arts
and sciences as any kind of dichotomy
to be a complete person it makes sense
to
be educated in both so having a vibrant
arts program
at a school like mit is is important for
making complete human beings for making
human beings that connect to the world
as you know there's things that happen
in a concert that can't happen in
rehearsal
everybody brings their best game and
also
as a listener as a composer you can
really let go
it's just the concert this is what it is
it's just time to enjoy it and let it
flow
the first movement gives us a sense of
place which is the middle east
and has a short section which
talks about the event that sparked the
arab spring which was the
self-immolation of mohamed bouazizi
and goes on to musically illustrate
how that event led to uprisings all over
the middle east
one so
the second movement is a very reflective
and quiet
movement in which i'm imagining the
participants
and observers of the events of the
spring
just taking stock of what has happened
and
reflecting on it
so
so
and the third movement is a call to
action or a call to continue to action
you know in the hopes that what happened
in the arab spring
continues to bring um better political
and human situations in the middle east
music is clearly one of the great
innovations of humanity
passed on to us from nature
the word awakening kind of conjures this
idea that
you're coming forth with something but
yet it might not be fully realized
this power of reflection and
contemplation is so
needed today and i think that awakening
in its own way
provides a vehicle for that
you